hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones brand vision
video just careful for spoilers from
episode six if you haven't seen it yet
there were a whole bunch of brand
flashbacks that want me to talk about
just a bunch of really quick cuts I
totally feel like they couldn't have
gotten away with something like that in
an age before web viewing where you
could rewind really easily it would have
just been completely terrible but there
are a couple big things going on in
these flashbacks two big phrases that
are really important where's my sister
and burned them all so obviously one is
the Mad King flashback Jaime's King
Slayer moment where the Mad King was
getting ready to douse all of King's
Landing in wild fire
he'd been driven completely mad and had
been pushed over the edge by Robert's
rebellion
he'd been steadily going bad for a long
time Daenerys is also a big part of the
visions they use flashbacks from earlier
seasons to show drogon flying high then
it shows a shadow of a dragon flying
over what looks like King's Landing
it's basically brand getting the
information that he needs to fight the
night's king because we also get a
flashback to the night's king creating
another white Walker we see hardhome
from last season so brain is just
learning ways to fight the white Walker
and some of the important players is
basically him connecting the dots for us
the audience like Oh Dragons going to be
very important Jon Snow going to be very
important wildfire going to be very
important so a lot of people when they
heard that burn them all moment are like
maybe bran caused him to go mad and
that's why he said burn them all because
brain was thinking about burning the
White Walkers it's really the other way
around I think
brain is getting the idea after hearing
the Mad King say burn them all o burn
all the whites because the vision comes
after this big heart home scene no
surprise that then after bran wakes up
and the whites have found them they're
getting ready to kill them benjin rides
in and burns a bunch of whites so this
is just the show beating you in the face
with a battle plan they have a loose
plan now we need to burn them but it's
not like bran has a bunch of wildfire
that he's hauling around and the Dragons
haven't made it to Westeros yet so
there's just a couple weapons they need
in the people to wield them so first and
foremost all these visions are about
fighting the night's king and his army
stopping them but there's also a bunch
of other stuff happening here the reason
why we see this
big Mad King flashback in this episode
is because we're getting ready for a big
Jamie episode and thus far this event
has defined Jamie's life of all the
great things that he's done the big
battles he's been involved in the
smiling Knight his relationship with
Cersei everyone still thinks of him as
the Kingslayer no matter what he's done
since then he's still a Kingslayer so
it's just the show paying that moment
off before a big Jaime episode because
we're going to Riverrun we're gonna see
the blackfish so really defining moment
in Jamie's life preceding a big Jaime
episode the Lyanna stark flashback part
of this the ned promised me moment from
the book where ned stark presumably
takes the baby jon snow hopefully
they'll confirm that that's just what
everyone believes happened in the book
Lyanna stark extracted a promise for ned
but george RR martin never said that he
took a baby from the Tower of joy
it's just that fans have just been
pointing to a bunch of book evidence
saying oh yeah that's probably Jon Snow
he's part of the promise that he made
but Lyanna stark was a big part of what
set off Robert's rebellion in the first
place like this Mad King flashback was
at the tail end of Robert's rebellion
Lyanna stark was abducted before it
started that kind of precipitated things
that led to other things happening that
just snowballs into Robert's rebellion
so I know these really quick cut
flashbacks were kind of hard to follow
but then in this other brand flashback
from the Hodor episode is brand watching
Rickard stark leave presumably to go
talk to the Mad King to try and get
Lyanna Stark back so what happened is as
Rhaegar abducted Lyanna then Rickard
stark went to the Mad King with Brandon
Stark Ned's older brother they
petitioned the Mad King to try and get
Lyanna stark back but trial by combat
was called in the Mad King chose fire as
his champion so he didn't think he was
mad before he's definitely crazy at this
point Rickard stark gets roasted over
fire Brandon stark gets his arms tied
behind him and ended up choking himself
to death trying to reach his sword to
save his father to save Rickard stark
that was the big tipping point for
Robert's rebellion where Robert was like
oh [ __ ] is on so he rallied the banners
using what happened to Rickard stark as
this catalyst like look see what he did
to this person
that you love so much the warden of the
north roasted by the Mad King we need to
get rid of him so he used that to rally
people to his cause
Robert's rebellion happens they are
still searching for Leo Stark so at the
tail end of it Ned Stark finds himself
at the tower of joy where's my sister so
even though Ned Stark and bloody Lyanna
stark here don't seem connected to
fighting White Walkers it's just because
Jon Snow is going to be a big part of
that and it's also a big part of
Robert's rebellion so the show is paying
off the war for the dawn and Robert's
rebellion all these things that are
talked about by the characters in the
novels but you never actually see
because the novels pick up after
Robert's rebellion so for all the times
people complain about stuff that Dan and
Dave change from the book stuff that
they cut out I think that they're trying
to do something really awesome for the
fans by doing it this way because the
three-eyed Raven basically gave brand
the entire collected knowledge of what
happened in Westeros so like he could
flash back to balerion to Aegon the
conquerer to learn about dragon fire he
can learn about wildfire somewhere else
because wildfire wasn't created by the
Mad King so if he needed to learn how to
fight White Walkers there are so many
other points in history that he could
have flashed back to but the show just
wants to show you Robert's rebellion to
keep the narrative a little bit tighter
and to highlight these other big
characters that are currently on the
show right now so they're keeping the
show as linear and self-contained as
possible just easier to follow
especially for people that have never
read the books so the good news is is we
get to see all these awesome flashbacks
I got so excited when we saw this Mad
King flashback but it also means that if
we get a spin-off series it probably
won't be this it's not like they're
going to retread all the stuff that
they're showing us some flashbacks I
think they did a spin-off series they
would definitely go with duncan egg or
something else duncan egg is just the
leading candidate right now that they
would choose to do a series that is
somewhat familiar like a lot of the
names the surnames the houses the places
in Westeros would be familiar all over
the world but the characters would be
completely different
so when slightly related news I know a
lot of you are asking about the visions
that Daenerys had at the house of the
undying so there's been big changes
between the show in the books Daenerys
has way more visions than we saw play
out on-screen and a lot of them have to
do with the prophecy of the prince who
was promised seeing her brother Rhaegar
Targaryen the things that TV show
I saw were really potential futures like
she sees her baby with Khal Drogo that
ended up dying so we know that didn't
come to pass we also see the throne room
in the red keep that looks like it's
been destroyed and it's snowing so she
sees a nightmare scenario even though
she doesn't totally understand what's
going on it'll make more sense when she
gets there as she gets to Westeros
eventually she'll start to learn about
what's going on eventually she'll learn
about the White Walkers she'll probably
commune with bran little but I'm hoping
for like some Daenerys bran visions like
hopefully brand goes all three-eyed
Raven on her and gives her visions
without her totally understanding it
like oh my god White Walkers we need to
worry about this
we need to worry less about conquering
Westeros I know there's been a lot of
talk about Mad Queen Daenerys that's
mostly for fun the show just wants you
to think that she's going to be a
villain this conquering person that's
gonna fly into Westeros and destroy
everyone until the reversal when she
learns about the White Walkers
but hopefully that explains a little
about brans visions why they chose those
moments to show on screen specifically
we're brain is like a library now I mean
if bran really wanted to he could flash
back and look at egg on the Conqueror
and learn about all these same things
like oh I need dragons I need wildfire
so it's not like Dan and Dave are just
spinning a wheel when they're trying to
choose which flashbacks to show like the
Tower of joy flashback will probably
precede some big Jon Snow episode for
his army and Ramsay's army have it out
so brace yourself oh [ __ ] flashbacks are
coming and I do think that this season
will end on a slightly more cheer worthy
oh [ __ ] moment like last season Jon Snow
is dead in all the air just rushed out
of the internet like everyone's like oh
my god
I don't know what's going on what's
happening but I think at the end of this
season
it'll be somewhat similar only it'll be
a little more positive like you'll be
screaming because it's really intense
and it'll be a cliffhanger but you'll be
excited for the way they're gonna pay it
off next season
whereas with Jon Snow I think it was
more confusion just because so many
people hadn't read the books or hadn't
really read a lot of the Jon Snow
resurrection theories but that's a good
question let me know which episode do
you think that they're gonna finish
paying off the tower oh joy flashback
you know the baby like promise me that
you'll take care of this baby and what
kind of oh [ __ ] moment do you think that
will end the season on like White
Walkers marching south of the wall that
would actually be a pretty big oh [ __ ]
moment that people will get really
excited about because it's bad
but it's also really awesome because
it's going to be epic so either way
posting my episode 7 video later tonight
be sure to subscribe to get it there's
also a new round of the giveaway it's
just a $20 Amazon gift card all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll just
remind everyone when I post that episode
7 video just as a refresher if you guys
haven't seen it you can click here to
learn all about that tower oh joy
flashback R + l equals Shay the prophecy
of the prince was promised which is
actually pretty ambiguous and you can
also click here for my episode 6 video
from last week thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you